Rosie is a pensioner and the voice of a
million and a half more many of them
worried what the turbulence in pensions
markets means for them and the income
they rely on there is a great deal of
fear people don't actually know what the
future holds I think something which was
really worrying was when I heard that um
Trustees of pension schemes were being
asked to keep the resilience of their
Investments under close review which is
quite a concern I would think to many
the collapse in Market confidence in the
UK has affected defined benefit pension
schemes they guarantee a fixed annual
income to pensioners so all the risk
falls on the pension provider unlike the
more common defined contribution
pensions where payouts depend on the
performance of Investments around 18
million people are in defined benefit
pension schemes most of which are being
wound down but they still hold around
one trillion pounds worth of UK guilts
that's government dead which should
offer safe long-term returns but pension
schemes were exposed when the mini
budget caused a sudden drop in the value
of guilt the problem is that to
guarantee their payouts to pensioners
many funds have been using financial
instruments like borrowing against their
guilds to buy more guilds but when the
price collapsed they needed collateral
that's cash to offer their Banks and to
do that they had to sell guilts in a
hurry further driving down the price
until the bank of England stepped in
for two weeks the bank has been buying
guilts to boost the price and give funds
time to balance their books that says it
will stop on Friday a deadline the
industry fears
we think the bank should keep its guilt
purchasing facility open until another
couple of weeks today even we can see
Guilt yields Rising there's a lack of
confidence and so I think there is a
risk that there'll be problems and then
I'd imagine the bank would need to step
in with some other type of action right
so what I'm showing you here individual
pensioners should be protected for now
this is a question of liquidity cash
flow for Pension funds not their
underlying value and the advice is clear
stay where you are if you feel there's
any doubt if there is any commentary
around your scheme about possibly how
being in deficit and not being able to
pay the pension then we would say that
the most important thing you do is seek
professional qualified advice
Pension funds have 48 hours to restore
order should they fail the bank's
credibility may be on the line too Paul
Kelso Sky News in the city of London